and maybe your principal.
What do you think?"
And Elijah said,
"Dad, I have a better idea."
And I said, "Really? What's your idea?"
He said, "We have a public speaking assignment,
and why don't I use that public speaking assignment
to talk about debunking the myths of Rosa Parks?"
And I was like,
"Well, that is a good idea."
So Elijah goes to school,
he does his presentation,
he comes back home,
and I could see something positive happened.
I said, "Well, what happened, son?"
He said, "Well, later on in that day,
the teacher pulled me aside,
and she apologized to me for giving that misinformation."
And then something else miraculous happened the next day.
She actually taught a new lesson on Rosa Parks,
filling in the gaps that she had left and correcting the mistakes that she made.
And I was so, so proud of my son.
But then I thought about it.
And I got angry.
And I got real angry.
Why? Why would I get angry?
Because my nine-year-old son had to educate his teacher
about his history,
had to educate his teacher about his own humanity.
He's nine years old.
He should be thinking about basketball or soccer
or the latest movie.
He should not be thinking about having to take the responsibility
of educating his teacher,
his students,
about himself, about his history.
That was a burden that I carried.
That was a burden that my parents carried
and generations before them carried.
And now I was seeing my son take on that burden, too.
You see, that's why Rosa Parks wrote her autobiography.
Because during her lifetime,
if you can imagine,
you do this amazing thing,
you're alive and you're talking about your civil rights activism,
and a story emerges
in which somebody is telling the world
that you were old and you had tired feet
and you just were an accidental activist,
not that you had been activist by then for 20 years,
not that the boycott had been planned for months,
not that you were not even the first or the second or even the third woman
to be arrested for doing that.
You become an accidental activist, even in her own lifetime.
So she wrote that autobiography to correct the record,
because what she wanted to remind people of
was that this
is what it was like
in the 1950s
trying to be black in America
and fight for your rights.
During the year, a little over a year, that the boycott lasted,
there were over four church bombings.
Martin Luther King's house was bombed twice.
Other civil rights leaders' houses were bombed in Birmingham.
Rosa Parks's husband slept at night with a shotgun,
because they would get constant death threats.
In fact, Rosa Parks's mother lived with them,
and sometimes she would stay on the phone for hours
so that nobody would call in with death threats,
because it was constant and persistent.
In fact, there was so much tension,
there was so much pressure, there was so much terrorism,
that Rosa Parks and her husband, they lost their jobs,
and they became unemployable
and eventually had to leave and move out of the South.
This is a civil rights reality
that Rosa Parks wanted to make sure that people understood.
So you say, "Well, David, what does that have to do with me?
I'm a well-meaning person.
I didn't own slaves.
I'm not trying to whitewash history.
I'm a good guy. I'm a good person."
Let me tell you what it has to do with you,
and I'll tell it to you by telling you a story
about a professor of mine, a white professor,
when I was in graduate school, who was a brilliant, brilliant individual.
We'll call him "Fred."
And Fred was writing this history of the civil rights movement,
but he was writing specifically about a moment
that happened to him in North Carolina
when this white man shot this black man in cold blood in a wide-open space
and was never convicted.
And so it was this great book,
and he called together a couple of his professor friends
and he called me to read a draft of it before the final submission.
And I was flattered that he called me;
I was only a graduate student then.
I was kind of feeling myself a little bit. I was like, "OK, yeah."
I'm sitting around amongst intellectuals,
and I read the draft of the book.
And there was a moment in the book
that struck me as being deeply problematic,
and so I said,
"Fred," as we were sitting around talking about this draft,
I said, "Fred, I've got a real problem with this moment that you talk
about your maid in your book."
And I could see Fred get a little "tight," as we say.
He said, "What do you mean? That's a great story.
It happened just like I said."
I said, "Mmm ... can I give you another scenario?"
Now, what's the story?
It was 1968.
Martin Luther King had just been assassinated.
His maid, "domestic" -- we'll call her "Mabel,"
was in the kitchen.
Little Fred is eight years old.
Little Fred comes into the kitchen,
and Mabel, who he has only seen as smiling and helpful and happy,
is bent over the sink,
and she's crying,
and she's sobbing
inconsolably.
And little Fred comes over to her and says, "Mabel, what is wrong?"
Mabel turns, and she says,
"They killed him! They killed our leader. They killed Martin Luther King.
He's dead! They are monsters."
And little Fred says,
"It'll be OK, Mabel. It'll be OK. It'll be OK."
And she looked at him, and she says, "No, it's not going to be OK.
Did you not hear what I just said?
They killed Martin Luther King."
And Fred,
son of a preacher,
looks up at Mabel, and he says,
"But Mabel, didn't Jesus die on the cross for our sins?
Wasn't that a good outcome?
Maybe this will be a good outcome.
Maybe the death of Martin Luther King will lead to a good outcome."
And as Fred tells the story,
he says that Mabel put her hand over her mouth,
she reached down and she gave little Fred a hug,
and then she reached into the icebox,
and took out a couple Pepsis,
gave him some Pepsis
and sent him on his way to play with his siblings.
And he said,
"This was proof that even in the most harrowing times of race struggle
that two people could come together across racial lines
and find human commonality
along the lines of love and affection."
And I said, "Fred, that is some BS."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Fred was like,
"But I don't understand, David. That's the story."
I said, "Fred, let me ask you a question."
I said, "You were in North Carolina in 1968.
If Mabel would've went to her community -- you were eight years old --
what do you think the eight-year-old African-American children
were calling her?
Do you think they called her by her first name?"
No, they called her "Miss Mabel,"
or they called her "Miss Johnson," or they called her "Auntie Johnson."
They would have never dared call her by her first name,
because that would have been the height of disrespect.
And yet, you were calling her by her first name
every single day that she worked,
and you never thought about it."
I said, "Let me ask you another question: Was Mabel married?
Did she have children?
What church did she go to?
What was her favorite dessert?"
Fred could not answer any of those questions.
I said, "Fred, this story is not about Mabel.
This story is about you."
I said, "This story made you feel good,
but this story is not about Mabel.
The reality is,
what probably happened was, Mabel was crying,
which was not something she customarily did,
so she was letting her guard down.
And you came into the kitchen,
and you caught her at a weak moment where she was letting her guard down.
And see, because you thought of yourself as just like one of her children,
you didn't recognize that you were in fact the child of her employer.
And she'd found herself yelling at you.
And then she caught herself,
realizing that, 'If I'm yelling at him
and he goes back and he tells his dad or he tells mom,
I could lose my job.'
And so she tempered herself, and she ended up --
even though she needed consoling -- she ended up consoling you
and sending you on your way,
perhaps so she could finish mourning in peace."
And Fred was stunned.
And he realized that he had actually misread that moment.
And see, this is what they did to Rosa Parks.
Because it's a lot easier to digest an old grandmother with tired feet
who doesn't stand up because she wants to fight for inequality,
but because her feet and her back are tired,
and she's worked all day.
See, old grandmothers are not scary.
But young, radical black women
who don't take any stuff from anybody
are very scary,
who stand up to power
and are willing to die for that --
those are not the kind of people
that make us comfortable.
So you say,
"What do you want me to do, David?
I don't know what to do."
Well, what I would say to you is,
there was a time in which,
if you were Jewish, you were not white,
if you were Italian, you were not white,
if you were Irish, you were not white
in this country.
It took a while before the Irish, the Jews and the Italians became white.
Right?
There was a time in which you were "othered,"
when you were the people on the outside.
Toni Morrison said,
"If, in order for you to be tall, I have to be on my knees,
you have a serious problem."
She says, "White America has a serious, serious problem."
To be honest, I don't know if race relations will improve in America.
But I know that if they will improve,
we have to take these challenges on head on.
The future of my children depends on it.
The future of my children's children depends on it.
And, whether you know it or not,
the future of your children and your children's children
depends on it, too.
Thank you.
(Applause)